[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros hoy en 5
minutos o con hablaremos sobre las
amenazas de protestas de derecha de cara
de la juramentación de joe biden el
próximo miércoles y de los planes del
presidente electo para comenzar a salir
de la crisis nos acompaña desde
washington de over the blue en el
director ex director de programas
globales en la casa blanca y ex
diplomático estadounidense bienvenido
señor brain y qué mensaje se le está
dando al mundo con este dispositivo de
seguridad que hoy tiene prácticamente
blindado el corazón de washington será
la investidura con el mayor despliegue
de seguridad en la historia del país
pues sin duda y hay mucha excepción aquí
en las calles de washington
en esos días nunca he visto a tanta
seguridad aún en los días después del 11
de septiembre de 2001 otras amenazas a
las cuales
hemos tenido que confrontar aquí en
washington
un nivel de seguridad sin presidente y
sin duda y es triste y es una imagen que
la democracia aquí en los eeuu está en
riesgo
los temores a los ataques durante estos
días tras lo ocurrido el 6 de enero han
llevado a varias investigaciones de
grupos de extrema derecha incluso ya se
habla de investigaciones a las tropas de
la guardia nacional en dc puede haber
preocupación por ejemplo por un ataque
interno dentro de las filas pues
justamente a esta mañana salió un
reportaje que a haití rey evaluar los
soldados que están protegiendo a la toma
de poder de propaguen porque hay
inteligencia que podrían haber casos de
soldados que tienen la intención de
hacer algo no lo sabemos exactamente
pero como vimos el 6 de enero
hubo soldados ex soldados policía que
estaban atacando algo por camps salió
entonces hay este riesgo aquí está
bastante alto por la parte de las
fuerzas de seguridad y él
señor rubén hay antecedentes de
blindajes similares de las ciudades de
eeuu o de marchas por motivos similares
pues hay casos obviamente tuvimos un
verano bastante difícil con las
manifestaciones de blackwater
y había que proteger edificios del
gobierno en
[Música]
aquí en washington y también en otras
ciudades de los eeuu
sin embargo el nivel es sin presidente
el hecho que tenemos más de 20.000
soldados en las calles y su presencia
hay aquí a comentar aquí que en los eeuu
nosotros no tenemos el hábito de ver los
soldados en los edificios del gobierno
hay una división importante que siempre
hemos guardado entre los civiles y los
militares hoy en día
esta división se desaparecido
mire iniciamos una semana que es
histórica para eeuu en términos
generales en medio de tantos temas como
planeaba y de sacar al país de la crisis
económica sanitaria y social y en medio
además de un nuevo juicio político
contra donald trump usted como ve que se
proyecta esta semana
pues vayan va a intentar desde el primer
momento a tomar con control y hallar la
imagen que él está tomando acción
entonces tiene varias decisiones
ejecutivas
para cambiar las políticas que él puede
correr en todo el acuerdo del cambio
climático de parís algo respecto a la
participación de los estados unidos en
la organización mundial de salud pero
también la prioridad va a ser en la vida
y en la economía aquí en los estados
unidos él va a necesitar el apoyo del
congreso afortunadamente tienen mayoría
en el senado ahora y con la cámara de
representantes entonces él va a intentar
adelantar por lo que él puede y buscar
ayuda de la parte del parlamento del
congreso aquí en los estados unidos
gracias a usted ya nuestros televidentes
continúen con las programaciones de
france 24 buenos días
[Música]